all right so here it is I started doing
YouTube videos a little over a year
after Iron Man and The Incredible Hulk
came out in theaters and with the
Avengers coming up and a little over a
month I felt it would be a tragedy among
the world of tragedy if I didn't review
those two movies before the Avengers so
now let's do Iron Man Iron Man I said
when Iron Man was coming out and the
trailer came out I was like all right
Robert Downey jr. is gonna be great in
the movie his timings gonna be perfect
he's gonna be funny he's gonna be witty
the movie itself is gonna be some 90
minute piece of [ __ ] that's gonna suck
then I saw Iron Man and to the universe
I apologize I was wrong I'm pretty sure
at that point it was like my favorite
movie of that year until Dark Knight
you're too mainstream
yeah maybe so Iron Man's the story of
Tony Stark he's pretty much living the
rock star life among weapons dealers he
has no cares he has no worries it's all
about money women and just being plain
awesome and Robert Downey jr. really
nails this role the dude just kills it
as Tony Stark Robert Downey jr. shaped
the character of Iron Man in a
multimedia kind of way not everyone can
say that about the characters they do
now Iron Man still remains my favorite
Avengers Prelude movie I like how they
show how Tony Stark transitions into a
superhero because Tony Stark initially
is just not a superhero
initially you're like Tony Stark is such
an awesome character how do you make a
character who's already awesome more
awesome nay awesome tacular you have a
bunch of terrorists take him to a cave
and make him one of the greatest Phoenix
metaphors personified works for me his
time in the cave is one of my favorite
sections of the movie because it shows
how he goes from absolutely carefree to
a guy who absolutely gives a [ __ ] and
it's done really well I mean the movie
is funny it's witty it's action-packed
it's cool seeing Tony Stark create and
refine the tech that makes the Iron Man
suit just watching Tony Stark operate
it's gonna sound strange but it makes me
want to be smarter like I watch them
working on tech and I'm like I wish I
cracked down on math and engineering
actually it wouldn't be mad than
engineering shut up stop it it's nothing
engineering even if it's not math and
engineering it's math and engineering
don't take this from me
when he puts that suit on he actually
goes over there he takes out the bad
guys you're like yeah that is how you do
a superhero movie like this yes big
shocker ladies and gentlemen there are
people out there in the world who
control people with fear and murder the
innocent Tony Stark was just like all I
can either create a viral video
with the heartstrings of millions of
people throughout the world ask them for
money get money disable the comments in
that video then get caught lacking it in
public get arrested for that thus
destroying any and all credibility that
your video gets kind of like yeah yeah I
went there or you can create an Iron Man
suit and just go take care of the
problem yourself he does the second one
Iron Man was the first movie leading up
to the Avengers it's still the best
movie in my opinion leading up to the
Avengers it didn't feel like an Avengers
prequel it was just a solid movie in and
of itself the fact that it's leading to
bigger and better things
it's life having its little bonuses
right there so great acting great
characters great excitement great humor
that mixed well with everything else a
solid start to the Avengers lineup a
solid story in and of itself in a really
good story of redemption of one guy Iron
Man is awesome tacular
so if you seen Iron Man what did you
think of it comment below let me know
and I'll be doing the Incredible Hulk
here pretty soon - Edward Norton one you
know the one that matters and ever
happened ever and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more